welcome to this video this is a new part
new episode of the modern classics
serious in fact I think it's part 5 if
I'm not mistaken and yeah today I will
go back in time to 1996 and we'll have a
look at the game between Garry Kasparov
playing white and Vladimir Kramnik
playing black I'm a few words about the
the time that we look at 1996 at that
time Kasparov was the world champion of
his own Federation so to say he not left
feed in 1993 for the match the Nigel
shot and defended his title
two years later against Anand and yeah
well Karpov was world champion for
feeder it was clear that Kasparov was
the strongest player and he had the sort
of logical view of the court that way
world champion and kramnik was some
widely recognized as the most likely
successor of Kasparov in fact Kasparov
himself had on more than one occasion
said that he expects to defend his title
against Kramnik end yeah probably lose
it at some point of course he didn't
tell it that way but he thought that
Kramnik was a worthy Challenger at least
so this was really a big game at the
time where yeah everyone was curious to
see if Kasparov was still the best on if
the young challenger could could do
something this was played in a
tournament in Spain and dos hermanas
Kramnik at the time was 20 years old or
21 I'm not quite sure but his birthday
so I'm still very young
if you think about it 16 years ago and
kramnik is still world number two so
um nothing much as has changed at the
top Kasparov retired of course but okay
so let's see what would happen Kasparov
playing a default he played both d4 and
e4 against Kramnik and I'm not quite
sure about his success rate well I think
he's got better with deform okay we've
got d5 and Slav which was chrome legs
main defense at the time that we get a
semi Slavia and yeah at the time chrome
nakum played this almost exclusively he
still plays it today from time to time
but it's not his main choice yeah here
white of course has some two main
options III and Bishop g5 Kasparov um
has played both in his career
I think Bishop g5 he was more successful
with he also have tried it against put
on the brought against Kramnik come
nakum in fact played against Kasparov
and rapid chess more than once d takes
he for the board winning variation which
is of course one of the sharpest
Alliance and chess and very very
complicated however in this game
Kasparov opted for e3 which looks modest
in comparison to Bishop g5 but still
leads to very sharp plain omelet can
lead to very sharply might be g7 Bishop
d3
and now kramnik enters the marin
variation with taking on c4 Bishop c4
and b5 Bishop to d3 back and Bishop to
d7 in general blacks idea is to play a
six cover b5 and then play c5 so he
wants to Frias his heaven bishop in fact
instead of Bishop d7 there's also the
some would I would have move a six
directly preparing loops c5
and in fact this was the main
battleground in the 2008
World Championship match between Kramnik
and honored but here Kramnik in 2008
Kramnik played white and anand played
black so kramnik has accumulated a huge
amount of experience in these lands with
both thoughts affect kramnik lost to
white games and this World Championship
match at the beginning and this
basically decided the mansion favor of
Anand
okay but here kramnik played Bishop to
b7 Kasparov with castling alternative
would be the immediate ofor but castling
is maybe somewhat sharpen a6 you formed
c5 so both sides some yam managed to get
what they wanted white managed to play
for and free as bishop on c1 and black
got his some cons rolling on the Queen
side so that this bishop has some some
function and this is also why white
plays d5 he wants to blunt this bishop
and yeah get to open the file in case of
e takes d5 which would be very risky
just just have a brief look at this what
shelter should like do now the problem
is you cannot really take this just
something like this is terrible for
black he just um is just too slow with
this development and black is in deep
trouble so black cannot cannot take on
d5 and of course he doesn't want to play
e5 but black is usually allowing in this
kind of position is that white takes on
e6 he played them the normal move c4
here the ship c2 and Queen c7 this is
some the normal yeah way to play this
there's a move order nuances but in
general black advances a cheap
in some at some point and therefore also
gets ideas like 95 or Bishop c5 going
it's a it's a very complicated and sharp
struggle in the center and usually the
next couple of moves a very concrete for
both sides and we see that Kasparov is
some immediately putting pressure on a
critical point he played Knight to d4
therefore intensifying the pressure on
e6 but chrome League answered with
Knight to c5 in turned cover in this
pawn and yeah here because power of
opted them from a very very straight
forward continuation which is um yeah in
a way typical of his style he am also
most likely um had like a great
preparation and played before of course
this has played sixteen years ago so
it's not the age of heavy computer
preparation of course they used
computers back then also but they were
much much weaker and they really could
not be trusted to be honest so it's not
like like today where some variations I
worked hour to till move thirty or
something they they played much more
yeah at the board then at home so before
attacking the knight and the a black
doesn't have much choice he cannot move
it so it took to convey three on consult
and after this white reduces threat of
before and yes in a way forces like to
play before himself there's not much
choice otherwise there simply a.m.
before coming or at some cases f4
so before it's logical Knight to e4
and Knight takes e4 so black one a
central pawn and at first side you could
to ask yourself okay what is y doing he
just gave up the central pawn but it's a
very very concrete idea
Kasparov took only form recaptures and D
takes ecigs yeah in fact um if you look
at this position then okay let's put the
next black move on the board Bishop e6
if you look at this position um it's um
it's a very unbalanced position black
has got two excellent bishops which in
fact even pointing towards White's King
side he's got a nice night on e for an
active piece and white has a knight on
the rim which is somewhat questionable
question we placed sometimes the test
ideas here but it's still on the rim so
is this just good for black one the the
problem is that black has exactly one
issue here and this is for the King if
black would have one extra tempo here
let's say just cancelling then black
would be um yeah almost winning in this
position two bishops and yeah much
better position pieces but this is not
the case the problem is some very
concrete nature white took on f7 and
okay we need to take with the Queen if
you would everything f7 look stranger
but the problem is this move and now
White has ideas on only six so this was
in fact one of the points of White's
preparation the problem is that Kasparov
didn't really take into account what
what Kramnik played now he just
took with the Queen which in fact
involves a material sacrifice we see
what happens f3 and now the problem is
what about this this light where should
it go
if black retreats the night let's say 2
to f8 then there's rook e1 and that's
that's the big problem
what is blacks King doing now look at
this piece let's say King f8 what just
goes here and and wins this is the
problem the knight simply cannot move
let's say I'm for example also Knight c5
is not working after the check because
after King f8 you still got 96 and white
wins the house so this is the problem
and simply this Knight cannot move so on
black needs to get some very concrete
compensation now and he played Queen to
h5 which is fine threatening on edge -
yeah what now Kasparov played g3 which
is the best move you could also think of
F takes a form but have have a look at
this Queen takes here came here and
castles and yeah I don't think this is a
position where you need much calculation
that's a king here Queen here and this
is simply impossible to survive black
will get them get simply a winning
attack just too much on on the King here
here and so on so our g3 is the only
move and probably okay also for white
but of course um you need to
get specific variations now in this
position in fact kramnik probably didn't
play the best move but you need to be
aware that he had to solve this over the
board he didn't follow his preparation
or something all right so clump come
lick em in this position played them
castles and yeah sacrifice tonight
in fact as it turns out this isn't the
best move the best move would have been
a different piece sacrifice and this is
Knight takes g3 which leads to really
unclear play the point is after taking
on g3 that okay white needs to capture
their some not much else
and after this black simply can't simply
castles and I think this is the problem
for a human player you first second g3
and then just castle and okay of course
black has got two brilliant bishops and
wider as a piece on the ribbon but still
it's very very difficult to assess this
position the best defense for white
probably is rook a 2 which is some yeah
rather rather logical using the rook on
g2 or h2 and here in fact black has more
than one interesting continuation he can
take on g3 group g2 and Bishop e5 which
is probably enough for piece it's um
it's difficult to to analyze really
without spending yeah hours like has got
two pawns and a good good attack
he could also consider to play first
route 88 which in fact the computer
suggests um but this is rather yeah not
human move black of course has some some
some nice ideas let's say for example G
for Queen here Queen here and then one
key idea of black ass which should be 8
to a7 and yeah those diagonals are
something else in fact there are some
very concrete lines that might lead to
draw that's just for example have a look
at this and this is a draw we simply got
got this if white would would go here he
is not able to defend this and also this
ideas is in the position so there's
there's simply no move Queen here cut
this little little sidestep and what is
mated black some blacks the text simply
as is very strong ok back to this
critical position as shown now Knight XG
3 is probably best here leading to
unclear play maybe um it's a draw with
some perpetual it's possible with white
serpent King but chronic played castles
which is um as we will see not not as
good but it's very hard to to assess of
course yeah I'm here Kasparov doesn't
have a choice he needs to grab this
piece and he did
and now queen h3 this is crumb Nick's
idea the bishops are still raging and it
is very tricky to play but in fact here
Kasparov
yeah missed his chance to probably get
get a substantial advantage but this was
only possible with one move that she
which he didn't didn't find he played
Knight to f3 and instead could have gone
Queen to e2 and this is much stronger
the Queen protects the pawn and then
their ideas like win g2 coming in fact
here it's difficult to recommend
something for black a main problem is
that the may be intended move Bishop
reform is answered by Bishop to f4 and
this simply stops the the biggest
threats on g3 something like this should
be a clearly better for white there are
still some slides practical chances
because White's King is open but all in
all this sum should be a big advantage
for white um after Queenie year - um
yeah they of course many moves that
black and try one key point is that this
move which is also yeah quite quite
obvious is answered by Knight f5 and
this is very important um here in fact I
think black has no moves at all really
can we treat the bishop
and after this just Bishop b2 and this
is just not enough this night is a good
piece I'm offering some counter play and
shielding in a way White's King
something like this simply is not enough
for example if you go rook e8 to e8 with
these kind of ideas there's 96 and yeah
why this is just a piece of basically
for one pawn and it's it's it's simply
not enough Queen e2 was the big the big
chance that Kasparov missed in this game
in fact um if he had one weakness as a
player or maybe he had to he tended to
get nervous when the other player got a
concrete King side attack of course this
didn't happen so often because he was
just such a great player that it really
happened that people got King side
attack against them and he had some
problems if he really needed to put up a
really passive defense he tended to
defend all was actively which is natural
not normally a good way to play but
sometimes he he just played active moves
where where those were not possible
yeah in fact here Knight f3 was played
which is not a move that looks looks bad
at first sight detects the bishop and
provides some shelter for the King but
it simply fails to some very concrete
play yeah kramnik just sacrificed on g3
which was too expected but Kasparov must
have miscalculated something probably he
missed a key move a couple of moves
later he played Knight to c5 and in fact
this this loses the game what he could
have played which was better and put up
more resistance is again rook a to this
this defense but this is also very very
tricky because Bishop to b8 to a7
yeah in fact now that I look at it maybe
it isn't even improvement yeah the key
problem was Knight f3 yeah this in fact
looks looks even even worse then then
the game but the game was was also lost
just for example 95 you should a semi
you should be three and rook c8 and it's
basically impossible to keep all those
pieces together like is simply much
better coordinated with with the bishops
how to how to keep the night if white
would take on b7 there are some this
line coming and like is black is winning
no defense
so probably Nadia three already was was
the big problem and this position is
some more or less not not defensible
anymore I don't know maybe Queenie -
still Queenie - it was bought better one
month before but solid it could be an
idea if black tries the same then maybe
95 to ship is heaven Bishop here is some
is somewhat better in comparison white
also has this check possibly yeah this
is some better so maybe black can
shouldn't try to go to a 17-foot cover
cover c5 I don't know I'm just putting
some some moves on the board and maybe
here yeah this still looks like a super
strong attack yeah in fact I'm I
prepared some what for this video but
Queenie - was just a move that just came
to my mind don't have it in my notes
yeah it still seems like a very very
dangerous attack however what's clear is
that Kasparov smooth not c5 leads to a
lost position in fact kramnik here could
or not he could is the wrong word he
played it he had the chance to to second
other exchange and he did exchange
psyche on f3 which gets the King out
even more rook takes yeah Queen takes of
course was was an immediate made on h2
so therefore Luke takes Queen takes on
h2 and King f1 yeah and I think I'm it's
very likely that in his some
calculations Kasparov misses to the next
move if you want to use this game this
position as some sort of puzzle then try
to find the next move that black played
iam it's not super difficult really but
still very very nice touch okay I put it
put it on the board now if you want to
pause the video now the key moves that
Kramnik plate is Bishop to c6 which is
very strong this is exact maneuver
putting the bishop on b5 gets a key
attacking piece into the game and then
black will attack with all his pieces
he's a rook down at the moment but yeah
these pieces will get dominant positions
what should should Y do now he played
them Bishop to g5 at least covering this
square um there were some alternatives
but none of them really saved the
relatively best still the losing was
maybe Luke a5 with the attention of
Bishop here to take then Queen d5 coming
so Bishop b5 is just a blunder but black
cam can play at this Bishop c7 move
attacking the rook and if the rook
retreats then there still should be five
coming
yeah maybe what can play some tricky
move like this getting some some yeah
well very little counter play but black
is now two pawns up and it still has an
attack let's say something like this and
like should win
quite easily yeah white simply doesn't
have a defense anymore
so Bishop g5 was coming we should be
five check yeah
no choice what needs to retreat and here
the last key move rook to e8 which is
very strong
he just intends to capture one he ate
and get the rook into the attack as well
and that would be simply too much here
white has has simply no moves at all
there are some some needham made
possible Kasparov played Luke to a to
kind of a desperado move um what what
other moves are there let's say
something like this Queen here and that
is check coming and rookie form very
nice touches something like this with
with a unique double pin and yeah like
will matin and a couple of moves so this
is really a rare occurrence that
Kasparov um goes down to such an attack
I'm not quite sure if there's even a
comparable game in his who HS Korea at
least not in the last let's say 20 years
of his career when he was world champion
or close to that maybe as as a junior or
something but as a grownup as
Grandmaster and so on I think he never
lost in this kind of fashion any game
okay what did you play played rook a to
and in fact here chronic in time trouble
missed on a very simple win but okay
it's um it's a human thing here
he am he could have played Bishop takes
d3 rook takes no other move if Queen
takes and this this needs checkmate
so rook takes oops
rook takes and then this is a direct
checkmate so we missed them mate in
fourth but okay didn't he didn't have
much time what he saw umm it's enough to
win the game he played Queen to h1 check
King here King him and rookie 4 which is
um yeah enough to to win the game
King b2 here there's also this this need
idea again with the very unique
checkmate ok Kasparov played King King
here twin G to check and here yeah this
is what Kramnik saw with Queen h1
instead of the mate he saw that he gets
the rook back and now has simply
arranging attack white can capture the
bishop but after this it's a deadly pin
like will win d3 with check and it's
also close to giving mate he's also
three pawns up which is not not bad bad
at all
and he in fact Kasparov resigned the
game yeah this is probably the most
drastic loss that he ever suffered
suffered as a world champion and we see
that kramnik is not the yeah let's say
solid positional very slow grinding type
of player that he sometimes
it's caught but we can also play wishes
the Texan in fact in the 90s he played
very sharp very sharp systems very sharp
games and this is not the only game that
he won in this kind of way he only
changed the style a lot when he faced
Kasparov for the World Championship in
2000 and then he really changed his
style to a very very rock-solid
positional approach to not lose any
games with black especially and after
that we didn't see those kind of
attacking games so often so I'm let's
have a quick recap the spar off came up
with this this new idea but he
underestimated this Queen f7 resource in
this position Kramnik needed to
sacrifice on g3 with Knight XG 3 which
would have been better but he played
castles a different kind of peace
sacrifice which after takes on Queen
edge we could've backfired
if white would have played Queen e2 here
the fact he didn't do that and after
Knight f3 Bishop takes g3 yeah black is
already a better and has a very strong
attack which after Knight c5 yeah got
the decisive attack
and then the final very aesthetic touch
to the game is Bishop to c6 and Bishop
to b5 we just put up puts up boom yeah
crossfire of Bishops and this was too
much for Kasparov sking resigned just a
couple of moves later yeah this was in
fact the only win with black pieces
between Kasparov and ramnik they played
really a ton of in classical chance okay
and rapid something else but in
classical Chesham this is the only game
that was
one by black it was only white winsome
and Kramnik kept the positive score
against Kasparov um by the way and I
think he's um maybe there's some weird
weird statistics for one player or
something but I think Cromley gets the
only player to have a positive score
against Kasparov maybe there are some
people who had some results in the youth
like one game and they want it or
something but if there's a substantial
amount of games from nicosia when you
want to have a positive score against
Kasparov alright I hope you enjoyed this
game I think this was one of the most
spectacular games of the 90s especially
considering the players involved as
Kasparov really never lost in such a
fashion yeah I hope you enjoyed it I'll
be back with a new episode of the
serious some soon